vous connaissez ce truc
[Musique]
on est aujourd'hui chez samsung pour
aller parler va pas chez samsung met à
l'événement ça me semble pour aller
parler de nouveaux smartphones les à 50
nouveaux smartphones assez intéressant
vous allez voir reprendre les codes
qu'on connaît déjà petite encoche on
bulle enfin je vous en dis pas plus à
les voir très intéressant et vous me
direz ce que vous en pensez à vos
commentaires
on était avec mathilde de samsung sera à
l'avenir ça change et 6h en jeux de
londres on est bien de faire jouer ou de
londres on est dans un tout autre cadre
karen on est pas mal il fait beau le
ciel est bleu jaune au shoot et ont des
palois du four à pizza il fait très
chaud voilà donc s'ils ont déboulé nous
en voulaient pas de nouveauté
aujourd'hui ce soit sur une nouveauté
chez samsung a fait alors on va se
parler aujourd'hui donc dû à 51,50 donc
à 50 a été présenté une première fois à
barcelone au mw sim et donc là c'est la
première fois qu'on va le prix
la presse française donc ce fameux à 50
comme je pense que tu as pu le voir une
grande nouveauté à être au niveau de cet
écran design c'est des choses qui
changent tout changement cette année
donc au niveau de cet écran et sur 6,4
pouces écoute en écran vraiment
panoramique avec l'intégration ce utile
ici de la caméra frontale au centre de
l'appareil
ce qu'une compères en fait une surface
d'affichage 2 92%
au niveau au niveau de l'immersion c'est
ça
[Musique]
cette bulle en fait compter sur de
magnifiques c'est que cette dame
disparaît complètement c'est là vous
traitez moi et c'est donc l'immersion
est vraiment totale et tu peux vraiment
plongés au coeur de thé continue y est
pour quelque chose que tu as vu je suis
au niveau de cet écran d'ailleurs
comment j'ai verrouillé hong kong et
d'un capteur sur les fortes empreintes
digitales et c'est d'abord prendre un
lecteur optique
donc en fait on n'a même pas besoin de
déverrouiller de déverrouiller l'écran
il suffisait pas l'abonnement ça et
trompe quelques mois attentionné à la
con thorel mer
[Musique]
donc je n'ai même pas besoin d'allumer
mon écran en fait sur le déterminer donc
ça ça va être donc la santé trop si on
continue sur l'écran au niveau des
technologies on a bien évidemment
toujours les super amoled
d'accord je vais peut être faire la
messe des enjeux que des noirs et qu'on
fixe l etat meilleur contraste etc
on connaît le savoir faire de sa mission
en termes de besoins des clients là
dessus on dire là-dessus encore avec
lesquels ils sont produits j'ai une
question
oui c'est vrai que ça me semble s'était
jamais positionnée sur le fait de mettre
des encoches même si vous la fibule en
restant même sur les quelques petites
encoches goutte d'eau ça on va appeler
les bulles
c'est un positionnement qui est nouveau
de la part de la marque
oui c'est un positionnement qui est
nouveau après qui répond aussi toujours
aux besoins et aux attentes aux attentes
des consommateurs parce qu'elle était un
d'immersion en fait les en fait les
consommateurs ont envie d'avoir un écran
toujours plus grand poisson il remarque
aussi au niveau des usages en crète
on consomme énormément de contenu sur le
smartphone moi personnellement ça dans
le train etc
je fais de maîtrise et 150 que sur
smartphone les écrans sont en plus en
plus grands et du coup cette petite
goutte vraiment permettre en fait
d'avoir un écran toujours plus grand
mais en format informatique de ses
contacts un peu alors que ceux ci ont
vraiment ce à l'intérieur de notre
question c'est pas le classement j'ai là
le chef du ce oui avec la jolie coque à
paillettes vous avez intégré la petite
bulle à l'intérieur sur le côté c'est
pourquoi vous voulez différencier les
gars c'est une dizaine de minutes par
une différenciation au niveau des gares
aux quais avant voici une certaine
montée en gamme et c'est ok cool joly
parfait donc ça un point de vue de la
grande qualité immersion grand écran
très sympa constitution continue sur le
design nous suffit de tourner le mobile
donc on va avoir quatre couleurs on va
voir leblanc ici allez on va tous les
faire je le veux ici le noir dégrader
alors tu vois plus un petit rire d'elle
une heure et pour finir le corail
donc comme vous l'avez peut-être vu
l'ensemble de cette gamme a en effet
qu'on appelle prismatique ce petit côté
irisé ses sorties que tu rentres
voteront sur l'ensemble de la gamme
voilà et au niveau de finesse aussi on
est sur 7 mm donc on est vraiment sur un
smartphone encore plus fin que la gamme
de l'an dernier donc en termes de prise
en main et c'est vraiment
canon
[Musique]
nouveau nom à 50 c'est un changement de
dénomination chez sony je suis vraiment
c'est ça un nouveau des méga ok voilà on
coule donc au niveau du design on est
pas mal j'ai vu qu'ils avaient de l'usb
se il y ait de l'usbc tout à fait ont pu
s baissé on a également de la charge
rapide auquel est ensuite au niveau
capacité de batterie on va être sur
quelque chose de
de très importantes 4 millions terreur
donc c'est vraiment une belle auto d'une
belle capacité d'accueil dans le hall où
l'on me voilà en termes d'autonomie avec
très bien de quoi tenir toute la journée
et ensuite le soir le recharger
rapidement avec la toujours par vous
faites charge un rapide coup là
si vous êtes fan de séries regardez j'ai
un truc qui est pas mal pour vous je
sais pas si ça vous parle ça c'est une
grande chaise et le trône de game of
thrones on va venir s'asseoir dessus et
on va faire le king je travaille je suis
john snow pas mal à regarder pour de
vrai
[Musique]
regardez-le harry potter toute la nuit
c'est que t'as pas vu harry potter mais
t'as vu qu'à mon sens les miens syrie
ces actes et aux beats et sa qualif et
moi ça ici voilà qui suivait c'est la
couleur en termes de performances et en
appareils de cette batterie qui est
importante
ensuite le deuxième gros points qui en
termes de performances sa belle course
qui va être stockage 428 jega de
stockage et tu vas vraiment avoir de
quoi de bach et de bazin nativement
d'abord 128 giga et bien évidemment
qu'il va retrouver encore donc ce port
microsd qui va te permettre en fait
d'étendre la mémoire jusqu'à 100 gwh
giga supplémentaires
donc tu peux vraiment faire de belles
choses avec ce police
mettre pas mal de contenu je suis comme
on dit on va également à mardyck la cime
d'un doublé 6 millions d'actions en
rénovation dans son tube avant deux ans
comme consigne est un emplacement
d'important il croise ensuite au niveau
père séparé du processeur si tu veux en
conversion un exit à 96,10 on va avoir
quelques gigas de ram au niveau de la
cadence 2,3 niveau clé du texte rappelle
ceci pour les pages dans la gamme et la
gamme race est très bien
donc ça c'était vraiment le bon bout
et pas des moindres ont très souple
quelqu'un qui ment pas
mais à quoi ça sert pourquoi donc alors
ce premier cas ça va être le capteur
pour le moment c'est un mur à faire tout
ce qui va être mon art de jouer ensuite
tu vas voir le second capteur ici tant
qu'acteur principal de 20 5 mégapixels
avec une version 2 est donc idéale pour
tous qui va être conditions de
la luminosité est enfin le dernis ça va
être ultra grand-angle 121 degrés merci
aux poissons du classique au niveau de
cette triple caméra armor à quoi elle
sert donc là on a le capteur principal
donc il va servir pour tout ce qui est
plutôt basse lumière en 25 méga pixels
une ouverture en 7 et ensuite on va voir
donc si triste le capteur
on va voir ici donc là on est sur un
nombre de villes sont dans 3 degrés vers
77 sur le terrain on peut vraiment voir
la plus value que ce capteur notamment
tout ce qui va être photo de groupe et
fausseront agents ensuite on va voir ici
le mode portrait bon malheureusement
j'ai pas de mannequin ici mais comme on
peut s'en douter ici on va avoir en fait
la profondeur de champ soit sans avoir
réglé avant ou après la plus on va
également avoir un mode ici
reconnaissance reconnaissance de scène
ici disent ils est désactivé et hop il
suffit d'appuyer et ensuite donc il est
capable de reconnaître jusqu'à 20 cents
différences marquées et en fonction
adapter les réglages la saturation des
contrastes et c'est donc ça c'était au
niveau de la caméra arrière
ensuite si on bascule sur la caméra
avant c'est très fluide et suivi de
switches ou coucou c'est nous relm il
est là donc là on a 25 méga trail au
niveau de la caméra frontale et on a
également un petit mode portrait qu'il a
et il lui confère une sorte tu vas
vraiment pouvoir régler en fait son
jeune arrière plan c'est donc là il
il a découvert les restes d'autres
smartphones qui vient s'adresser à des
personnes qui veulent un bon smartphone
de chez samsung mais qui veulent pas
forcément mais plus budget d'une gamme
est cette fois pas besoin d'autant de
performance autant de de spécifications
qu'on peut retrouver notamment sur
vitesse discus voir lequel il ya la
frontière entre le est de ceux là
et des produits comme cela tu vas avoir
des choses que tu retrouves pas sûr en
est typiquement la charge son chien
voilà quelque chose qui va être
uniquement soit d'accord ensuite il va
également avoir lippé 68 nouvelles sur
la grèce après sont pas pour autant que
la gamme à
et florence bègue au contraire
légèrement très riche et comme tu as pu
le voir il ya énormément de choses m en
termes de technologie et de performance
est vraiment un appareil qui elle rend
smartphones qui est vraiment puissant et
performant conservation de la prise
directe ça c'est cool c'est saint lô
parleur mono j'imagine souris sur le
banc j'avais devant moi il faut très
bien ça y compris j'en écoute restera
plus tard parlons tarifs maire de paris
ça ça coûte combien petit appareil comme
ça il sera au prix de 3 50 349 ça
très agressif au positionnement c'est
important câline et répondre ce produit
est
et on n'a pas de doute il sera justement
il sera disponible dès la semaine
prochaine les mêmes billets disponibles
en partant ok c'est certain
liambas approuvé les voir voilà pour
cette présentation rapide les nouveaux à
5 ans galaxie à 52 cents en dessous
comment vous les trouvez moi j'aime bien
tout ça c'est intéressant c'est une
proposition qu'on a déjà vu d'autres
fabricants néanmoins c'est intéressant
de voir comment samsung se positionnent
sur ce type au logis produit c'est
vraiment très très très intéressant on
en reparlera on testera attendant vous
invite à venir tout ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire comment
vous trouvez cela 5 ans parce que vous
trouvez intéressant l'idée de triple
module photo avec le grand temps où le
rock ça se développe énormément est ce
que c'est un outil qui vous parle
et puis qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
fait que samsung est mis cette petite
bulle alors on n'appelle pas ça une
encoche et samsung mais vous l'avez déjà
vu ailleurs
c'est pas mal voilà dites moi ce que
vous en pensez dans les commentaires
vous avez bien évidemment aller voir ma
playlist vous parle de tous les
smartphones du moment comme ça vous
serez tous puissent donne rendez vous
dès demain
à bientôt au tchad
[Musique]